the White House admits the developments
in Syria over this past week have
altered the tone of President Trump's
foreign policy his immediate response
ended up casting quite a diplomatic
shadow over a long planned summit at
mar-a-lago with Chinese President Xi
Jinping White House correspondent
Margaret Brennan is in Palm Beach
Margaret good morning good morning well
president Trump has had a busy past few
days hosting foreign leaders and
completely up ending his America first
foreign policy the day after the most
significant military action of his young
presidency mr. Trump wrapped up a
crucial test of diplomacy with China's
leader Xi Jinping
after dinner the night before the
president informed XI that US missiles
had just made impact in Syria the
decision to intervene in Syria's brutal
six-year war seemed a sharp departure
from the America first policy outlined
by President Trump on inauguration day
we do not seek to impose our way of life
on anyone
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson said
that the strike does not signal a new
u.s. offensive in Syria where they were
already nearly a thousand US operators
fighting Isis but at the UN on Friday
ambassador nikki Haley said it should be
seen as a warning we are prepared to do
more but we hope that will not be
necessary where do we go from here
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham said
strikes are not enough and that mr.
Trump needs a long-term strategy when
the early stages I'm glad they did it it
was a resetting moment it was
wonderful signal to sin but it's got to
be followed up and in Palm Beach
president Trump's policy on how to rein
in nuclear-armed North Korea appeared to
be starting to take shape he was not shy
and signaling that if Beijing doesn't
confront the rogue state he's willing to
go it alone
the question is what is the or else
military action on the Korean Peninsula
risks another war analyst Evan Medeiros
worked on China policy at the Obama
White House the challenge is that North
Korea under Kim jong-un has been doing
this for a while it hasn't seemed to
have persuaded China to do more so I
think this is going to be a real
challenge and a real test for the Trump
administration and North Korea is
expected to defy these calls for
restraint and carry out another test of
its expanding nuclear program the Trump
administration is preparing another
round of sanctions and a plan for
president Trump to soon visit the region
Anthony Margaret Brennan Thank You
Margaret